J'avais dit que je ne mettrai pas en ligne cette vidéo
mais vous avez été tellement nombreux à me demander de la mettre quand même
que finalement vous m'avez convaincu.
"Euh beh justement t'aurais pas dû la mettre"
(rires)
[bruit de gifle] Ferme ta bouche wesh.
Co-co-co-co-co-co-co-co-comment ils vont ?
Alors s'il y a bien une personne légitime pour parler de style, je...je pense que c'est moi!
FAUX
En fait en ce moment je suis dégoûté parce que je réalise que je suis né pour avoir un look banal.
Tous les trucs un peu stylés, exubérants sur moi font ridicules.
Les Dr Martens, sur moi, ça fait papy comptable
Un bob, sur moi, ça fait pêcheur du dimanche
Les mèches blondes
ça fait Tuche
La moustache, ça fait Tuche
Bon au fait sur moi tout fait Tuche quoi
Moi quand j'étais petit je pensais qu'il y avait un endroit, genre un bureau quelque part où des gens décidaient des modes
Bon les gars qu'est-ce qu'on lance cette année ?
Gontran tu nous rappelle le fonctionnement ?
-Ouais bah comme d'hab hein: un rappeur porte une fringue,
tout le monde veut être original en portant la même chose, ça devient "has been",
et là c'est vendu chez "H&M"
-Voilà ! Alors qu'est-ce que vous proposez là ?
-Alors cette année je propose de relancer les Charentaises hein,
mais les Charentaises "Off-White"
- Bah pour moi c'est aussi bien que de la diarrhée en fait.
- Mmh. Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
Tu veux que la boîte elle coule ou quoi?
Je te rappelle l'une de tes meilleures idées.
- Ouais nan, mais à l'époque j'étais en stage, donc ça compte pas, fin...
- Oui, sans compter la connerie que t'as lancé y a 2 ans.
J'crois qu'tous le monde s'en rappelle hein?
- Ouais, après j'étais en dépression aussi…
- Oui, après on n'oublie pas que c'est toi aussi qui a lancé la marque streetswag
- Ouais bon ça va, on a compris!
- Oh bah tant pis sinon, on refait des collabs hein?
On peut faire ''Gucci-Geox", ''Louis Vuitton-Quechua''.
- J'ai hyper chaud là.
Quoi?
- Attends mais c'est une pure idée ça!
- Bah c'est un T-shirt quoi.
- Un T-shirt ironique !
Genre tu portes un truc vieux, désuet, et ringard, et du coup ça devient stylé!
- Ouais, comme les t-shirts Jacques Chirac ou Céline Dion !
- Non mais c'est pas ironique hein, j'aime vraiment bien ce T-shirt.
- Mec, t'es un génie, let's go!
- Ça tue sa mère!
Au-delà des modes vestimentaires,
on dirait que en 2019, ça y est, tout le monde est tatoué.
C'est limite la norme.
Même les mannequins, quand tu vas sur les sites de fringues genre Asos et tout,
tu regardes les modèles...
le mec c'est pas un mannequin, c'est Swagg Man
Parfois les gens ils se font tatouer pendant un voyage.
Limite, on dirait que plus le tatouage a été fait à l'arrache au bout du monde,
plus c'est stylé.
- Mec, je me suis fait tatouer la main dans un petit boui-boui en inde
sur un coup de tête bourré entre potes, c'était un délire !
- Trop bien mec, et ça donne quoi ?
- Bah c'est infecté.
J'vais m'faire amputer dans 2 jours.
Regarde mon moignon, il bouge!
On dirait que les gens tatoués,
ils ont toujours une histoire à raconter sur chacun de leurs tatouages.
Et on dirait que c'est obligatoire qu'il y a un rapport avec la famille hein
- Ouais, j'ai un tatouage ouais. Mais c'est un peu personnel, je sais pas si j'ai envie d'en parler.
Bon vas-y je te dis, en fait c'est en hommage à ma grand-mère.
J'ai directement fait tatouer son déambulateur.
Je devais faire aussi son dentier
mais j'avais plus de thune.
Parce que à la base je suis graphiste
et je suis payé en bitcoin.
Mamie,
Tch-tch-ciao.
Si je me fais un tatouage un jour, j'ai trop peur de choisir un truc
qui est plus à la mode trois mois plus tard.
- Y'a quelques temps j'ai fait deux tatouages.
J'ai fait un hand spinner
et un mec qui dab.
J'ai... j'ai le seum, ouais.
Moi quand quelqu'un veut me faire faire du shopping, ça me fait très peu plaisir,
parce que ça fait genre…
- Mec ! J'vais t'emmener faire du shopping.
- Nan nan, t'inquiète, ça va.
- Ah non non, là je t'emmène faire du shopping.
Là ça craint, vraiment.
- Ah ouais?
- Allez viens.
Et quand un pote va au bout du délire et essaie de me conseiller en fringues,
bah ça se voit en fait.
- Bah alors gros, c'est comment les vêtements là ?
Bah c'est génial ! Et bah voilà !
On t'a enfin trouvé ton propre style mec!
- Appelle-moi Danny 2 si tu veux.
Y a des gens qui sont obsédés par les marques de fringue.
Il y a vraiment que ça qui compte, pas du tout le reste du vêtement.
- Je sais pas Norman. Bon après, c'est un t-shirt.
Blanc aussi, donc euh
Il est...
Oh la la!!!!!
- Incroyable ce T-shirt!!
- C'est quoi ce truc de malade!!
Mais en même temps c'est vrai que la couleur...
La forme et tout c'est pas... ouais...
OOOOOOOHHHH!!!!
- Nan.
- Ça te va pas.
OOOOOHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
- Franchement non.
- C'est pas ouf.
OOOHHH!!!
Alors les sneakers, parlons-en, hein?
Bon, c'est des baskets, mais il faut dire sneakers.
Moi j'ai trop de potes qui collectionnent les sneakers,
c'est vraiment leur passion.
Mais pas moi, moi personnellement je... Bah je m'en bats les couilles.
Par contre, du coup, je collectionne les potes qui collectionnent les sneakers.
Quand ils te parlent de leurs shoes on dirait des historiens.
- Ça, c'est le modèle édition collector des 20 ans de la tn
OG orange d'un côté, OG bleu de l'autre, c'est magnifique.
The greed le grillage dessous, c'est trop beau mon frère.
- Vas-y, mets les mec, ça tue.
- Mets les? Mais toi, t'es fou toi!
Putain!
Mais toi tu connais rien en basket en fait quoi.
Bon bref, tout ce que je vous ai raconté est totalement superficiel.
Le plus important, c'est d'être stylé à l'intérieur plutôt qu'à l'extérieur.
On peut avoir un style différent, se côtoyer, voir s'aimer
- Tu sais euh, c'est pas parce que t'as pas le même style que nous qu'on va arrêter de travailler avec toi.
- Bah c'est vrai ça ?
(tout bas) - Bah non.
- T'inquiète, la prochaine fois qu'on sort on t'appelle...
Surtout si on va chez Darty.
OOOOOOOOH !!!!!!!!!!!!!
Merci d'avoir visionné ce contenu vidéoludique,
j'espère que c'était pas trop relou.
Mais fallait que je le dise, fallait que ça sorte, tel du pus dans un bouton d'acné.
Tch-tch-tchao !
Tch-tch-tchao ! c'est un message codé qui va suivre
Tch-tch-tchao!